hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled choosing best system to
answer your question what question are
you to answer
is part one of our five part series on
organoids in this series you will be
better equipped to answer the basic
questions and feel unable to get started
using 3d culture systems I'm Christy you
love labradorite we'll be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by lab roots
and brought to you by thermo Fisher
Scientific to learn more about our
sponsor click on the thermo Fisher logo
at the left of your screen
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
sent we will answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have a bubble seen
during the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking question box located
on the front left of your screen this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
I now like to present today's speaker
David Cone injur director and group
leader
Thermo Fisher Scientific for a complete
biography on our speaker with a
biography tab at the top of your screen
David now begin your presentation
okay and thank you for that introduction
Christy so with that I will start with
today's webinar and that's going to be
the introduction to an overview of 3d
biology on discussing organic spirits
and applications relative to traditional
2d culture
moving on to our first slide so this is
really just taking a snapshot of the you
know the field in terms of publication
the publications that are you know
keyword searching under 3d models and
what you can see is that there's a
fairly substantial ramp up over the last
decade or so and a few of the key
highlights or representative sort of key
discoveries along the way are
highlighted here just notably work
identifying one of the adult stem cell
markers LG r5 in 2009 and then more
advanced more recent and advanced work
showing the IPS see derived mini brain
tech structures more complex cortical or
neuronal structures that are performed
using these approaches so lots of
interest lots of growth lots of
excitement in the field and really just
do you know a lot more substantive
advancements to come okay so what what
is a 3d model and no I think I need to
preface this and say this is you know a
a culmination of a number of viewpoints
I think that there is not exactly a
single hard and fast rule but but you
know this is you know again we've got to
sort of frame the discussion and have a
kind of a ground ourselves in language
and terminology and so that's what the
slide is meant to do and so really what
do we mean by you know 2d and this is
really just traditional monolayer
culture so shown on the Left where cells
are grown apparently on plastic and as
we start to transition into you know 3d
models these can be both you know not
non-adherent models which are showed
more in the center so with this
spheroids or organoids
or into more complex systems that can be
interconnectedness of different tissue
models the silk of organ organ ama chips
type of culture systems as well as
printing bioprinting I would broadly
fall in this in this category yeah so
we'll get into some more some more sort
of details and definitions of you know
how one might subdivide or think about
these various types of structures as we
keep going
okay so with that so yeah what what are
these are maybe the two main flavors of
3d models that one hears about or
referred to often lis these are
certainly not the only types of 3d
models but but certainly in a common
ones and so I thought it'd be useful to
include these the slide as a as a way of
help to differentiating or helping
define or contextually how these these
different types of cell structures can
can be different and on the Left we've
got steroids it's kind of a a definition
you know fairly for both definition on
here that'sthat's really I think the the
essence of it is that it's an aggregate
of cells typically well they can be a
single cell type or multiple cell types
and they generally will not self
organize in and forming more complex or
tissue like structures I don't organize
a bit and forming actually the
aggregates but but they tend to not be
to generate much more complex structures
and we'll talk about some specific
examples of spheroids monoculture
spheroids a little bit later and
highlight some of the reasons why you
know there are they can be advantageous
sources 2d and then on the right the
organoid definition and these are really
organized by a working definition tend
to be generated from cells that have
well have stem cell properties whether
they're pluripotent or whether they're
adult stem cells that is one of the sort
of common themes with organoids that
you're starting with a stem cell that
has the ability to self renew to grow
and also to differentiate into at least
a number of different cell types
depending on on the lineage and where
the stem cell comes from and a part of
this process of growth and
differentiation
comes with self-organization and so
that's where these more complex organ
and tissue like structures that that
recapitulated many ways aspects of
developmental biology can form when the
stem cells are cultured in it in a
specific environment so yeah so that's I
think in broad painting with a broad
brush that's that's how we consider
that's how I consider the key
differences between these types of 3d
structures
okay so going into the next slide this
is slide five
so one of the key sort of a common step
in the forming these 3d structures
whether they're steroids or our
organoids is the aggregation step so
you're typically starting with cells
that are individual individual cells
they could be coming off of a you know
sort of trypsin eyes off of a off of a
monolayer dish or perhaps even straight
from tissue or from sorting or for some
other methods so you start with
essentially singular eye cells and those
in the for blocker image here those are
for each quadrant those are the the
individual cells are shown on the left
side and then you basically set up an
environment that promotes aggregation
and there's four four methods are shown
here these certainly aren't the only
ones either sort of commonly used or
relatively commonly used one of the
upper left is sort of a hanging drop
method where you have cells in
suspension that's good actually a
hanging drop or a or the bottom of a of
a culture dish where you basically let
the cells cells aggregate on their own
based on either the fluidic properties
or this or shape of the flask so they'll
just settle down and sort of come in
contact with each other this will drive
aggregation for many many cell types
moving over from the top left to the
right there's other ways to do this we
can again we can gently centrifuge cells
into into pellets to help drive
aggregation again these are all going to
be in plastic where that or culture
vessels that you want to have either
coated for either that are not adherent
so we don't want the cells to actually
stick to the plastic or to the vessel
but to themselves and then the lower
half of the figure shows two different
sort of larger scale approaches for for
bioreactors or roller bottles where you
essentially put a suspension of cells in
and using cell densities education
culture conditions some other aspects
you can help drive aggregation and scale
so that's really kind of the requisite
first step in forming
swords or or organoids so
moving on to slide six so this is a
figure that depicts a number of the
tissues that have been reported this is
a little bit of a David the slices a wee
bit dated so there may actually be some
more updates to it but but it shows the
tissue types from from humans for which
organoids have been established and
these can be starting with with either
you know stem-cell induced IPSC models
the pluripotent stem cells or or using
adult stem cells which are derived from
that the tissue of interest or as
indicated here and I'll talk a bit more
about that on the later slide so now
kind of a growing array of tissues that
have been shown themselves to be
compatible with this type of bio in
vitro biology
yeah so if we looking at slide 7 if we
if we look a little bit more sort of
broadly at the types of cells that are
capable of giving rise to organoids and
and this in this case these are going to
be cells cells that have you know the
ability to both you know both expand and
and differentiate although come back to
the tumor lines or the exception here
but but essentially these are Lisa these
are progenitor cells or cells that have
a high replicated potential so up on the
upper left so these are adult stem cells
these are really they tend to be
epithelial progenitors they tend to be
stem cells derived from epithelial types
of tissues that undergo constant renewal
and have a relatively high abundance of
endogenous progenitors and so this is
where from the earlier slide where we
looked at many of those tissues you
probably notice that then many other
epithelials arrived and so these have
been thus far have led themselves most
readily to form form forming of organoid
so so the adult stem cells these are
typically from epithelial types of
tissues below that we've got the induced
IPSC cells it can be of course
reprogrammed from a variety of different
somatic cell types moving over to the
right upper right of this figure looking
at the tumor cells and these are cells
that can be isolated and expanded under
permissive 3d type conditions appear to
also be quite enabling for the
establishment of primary human primary
tumor lines and there's also kind of a
growing body of evidence that suggests
that the tumor tumor derived cells
isolated and expanded and analyzed under
these conditions also retain many of the
characteristics of the primary tumor
that that so such as clone ality may
in sort of heterogeneity of the prime
primary tumors and this makes them a
very interesting and attractive models
for for for disease modeling for for
looking at anti anti-cancer therapies
also and then on the bottom right this
is the embryonic stem cells this would
be the the yang to the IPS a yang if you
will
so again the bulk and I would say this
is you know this is for organoids these
are the cells that you know again retain
the ability to to both expand and
differentiate steroids to companion to
the organoids again a much wider array
of cell types can be used to form the
spheroid and I'll touch on a few of
those later in presentation
okay so if we look at again this is
using organoids as an example but it but
I think one generally at least from my
own perspective I think of I think it's
pharaohs as just significant as lower
complexity organoids and and that that's
a bit of a working definition for me and
if there may be examples where that is
entirely correct but but for the most
part I think it's probably a pretty good
rule of thumb and so generally when
you're forming spheroids they tend to
form quickly relatively quickly and they
tend to form with relatively low
complexity because of you're not you're
not
you have either relatively they're
monoculture or a small number of cell
types or you're not looking at at really
having complex differentiation programs
unwind in a culture setting organize
organoids are are can be more complex in
the number of cell types that are give
rise the types of structures the time it
takes to do this also so so I'm going to
go kind of taking that in mind the
bigger view kind of run through some of
the strengths and weaknesses of these
models and so we're looking at again
organoid formation either starting with
a human iPS see on the left or an adult
stem cell really there's there's a lot
of similarities between between the
features again they can again the
starting material is different that's
really the fundamental difference here
also I guess the relative developmental
state of these the IPS sees tend to be
you know fetal or embryonic like in
their relative maturity even as the
cells are differentiated starting with
adult stem cells you've got you know
cells that are developmentally a little
further along than the IPS es both can
be you know can create complex
structures that did the cancer models
come from those on the right they can be
expanded and bad
they're they're both compatible given
the expanded relatively large expansion
phase of these both of these cell models
can be you can undergo editing
correction and you know inducing disease
related mutations correcting them adding
reporters you know tinkering with these
from genetic standpoint which enables
the modeling disease modeling and
various other applications they're
indicated here
being at slide 9
so again these are some of the
challenges that are currently you know
that that investigators face as they're
working with these different models so
this is a slide layouts the same and in
some ways many of the the challenges are
quite similar you know one is
consistency this tends to be a bigger
issue with the IPSC derived lines as one
can generate much more complex cellular
structures than with the adults so so
again you've got the induced the IPSC
cells or not not lineage restricted at
least by you know by nature by their
starting point the adult stem cell
models you know are are going to be more
restricted to the tissue from which they
were derived so so in some ways they're
sort of developed the developmental
paths they can undergo or or narrower
and these tend to overall have a greater
consistency that then some of the
certainly with with many of the stem
cell direct models the IPS seeks Rd the
induced pluripotent stem cell line
yeah the protocols can be long and
complex particularly with the stem cell
derived models consistency is still
overall consistency can be a challenge
again in maturity with the the IPS SI
derived scale is is a challenge for both
without I won't get into the details of
the culture conditions or or how to
scale at this point I know there are
many people working on this but but it's
still still a real challenge so kind of
the throughput and assays and this is
really an important aspect that you know
you can appreciate so much of the
instrumentation assays reagents general
approaches and even benchmarking data
it's all built out or the vast majority
is built out on 2d cell models
so you know converting or you know
shoehorning assays that that you know
we're used to using into 3d applications
it can require require some creativity
and also some real technical challenges
because some things are just very very
difficult to to translate directly from
from 2d to 3d I'll touch on some of this
turns you into the presentation
okay so I'm speaking of 2d so here's
that if we want to do a high-level
comparison or just kind of thinking
about some of the key features of a
traditional 2d culture system versus
versus 3d and you know and so in some
ways you know why would you want to you
know 3d I hear a lot about 3d for
example but you know how can I use it
what's the value for the types of
problems that are looking at and and
this slide is again adapted from a paper
that's a few years old now and I think
maybe it's a bit of an
oversimplification but I think it does
kind of give you sort of the broader
broader comparison of 2d and 3d systems
and so you can I won't read the entire
slide you can you can kind of walk
through it here but you know looking at
you know just sort of morphology you
know time to create models overall
applications with with drug screening
with different types of assays cost
etcetera so you can you know you can
start to think about you know really the
fundamental drivers or at least the
thought the thought the wishin and the
promise of the 3d models are they're
going to be more representative of in
vivo situations of which are you know
where where we have cells in a not
typically not growing on plastic but but
in a three-dimensional environment now
you know one might consider that you
know in in vivo there's a lot of other
interactions
you know how cells health systems are
interconnected how cells and tissues and
how communication works how feeding a
nutrient delivery works is all you know
we're still a ways from from actual
physiology but generally cells can adapt
a more you know normal phenotype are
more normal like more in vivo like
phenotypes in in 3d
again the 3d cultures can take in a long
time
to form you know to form mature and be
able to use their complex structures so
this again provides challenges with
certain types of assays particularly
against lack of validated assays or say
a paucity of them as the you know as as
protocols as the 3d systems are becoming
more readily more reliably made as you
know sort of appropriate benchmarking
data is being generated as we just get a
better better sense for really where are
the times that the models are going to
make the most sense to use and other
times that the 2d systems may be
adequate so I think from my perspective
are still you know we're still kind of
defining what or what or when does a
particular model make the most sense and
you know again I think you could use a
table like this as as a way to help help
define that because certainly from from
a from a model complexity from a
biological complexity the 3d models are
very attractive but they take a long
time generally to make they have
generally more inconsistency than the 2d
models they're more expensive generally
but typically because of time but
sometimes the types of reagents that are
used to so so again it's there's a I
think it really depends on the type of
question you're asking at the timeframe
that you're working in and some
budgetary constraints also are
consideration okay so moving on to slide
11 so I'm showing here this is really
just kind of thinking about one aspect
of biology and where we organoids
spheroids may be helpful and that's
that's within the drug discovery a
process at a pipeline if you will so
this is a bit of a complex slide but I
think it conveys some interesting points
and if you start at the top and working
down it's really you know when you when
you're look
at during drug development there's
there's typically a kind of an upfront
tart target ID and then a screening
process that that where you'll you know
sort of winnow down a fairly substantive
number of potential drug candidates
where you know you really need
throughput and you want to be able to
make good good selection choices and
then once you start to to winnow that
list down you want to come in and you
know and say what are the what what are
the most efficacious compounds you know
this is sort of the lead optimization
preclinical work you start to do some of
the early toxicity and then and then
getting into your you know your your
face WC your clinical studies so you
know it
organoids and spheroids have promised in
this workflow and i think you know right
now it wants I think it remains to be
seen if we we get better productivity on
the targets of a de at a you know at a
large scale although there's there's an
awful lot of interest in this right now
clearly there's been the use of
organoids and the cancer tumor odes if
you will for personalized medicine or
doing drug screening sort of a real-time
or or or or both not only screening but
looking for therapeutic optimizations
while a patient is no undergoing
palliative care is is happening now so
this is some sort of very exciting
aspects here how scalable this is can we
start to use these and more predictive
you know sort of safety testing and as
well as speeding either reducing the
number of animals or speeding you know
the route to the clinic is these are all
promising applications I as far as I
know they're you know this is an area of
active investigation so you know I think
we're we're on the path to saying
exactly where you know we're organized
fit really where the real value value is
going to be in this workflow but but
certainly there's there's a lot of
potential
okay so with that I'm going to move into
a few specific examples of either from
work we're doing that's are my Fisher
Scientific or just highlighting work
that's been been done in the field using
various so this 3d spheroid or or
organoid models
so the first I'm going to talk a little
bit about hepatic spheroids so these are
going to be specifically aggregates of
hepatocyte or this is actually slide the
showing how Excel line at g2 cells but
but the concept is some more fruit for
primary path of sex and I'll show you
some data but but really just to orient
ourselves so the cartoon on the left is
a depiction of you know what what a
cartoon depiction of what a steroid of
cells is like and what you can have at
the core so it's a really a dense ball
of cells they tend to state depending on
how one forms them they start small they
can proliferate and then sort of get to
varying sizes depending on sort of the
seeding how you start and how long you
culture the cells but but at the core
once the the the steroids get large
enough you run into the diffusion limits
basically you end up with cells that
that can't don't have access to way
nutrients can't process waste accurate
well and end up dying or so you have
this sort of core in a chronic zone you
have outside of that an area where the
cells are not are quieted so not
actively growing but but not dead at
least black by some standard measures
and then the outer core where you have
this or proliferative zone and it's the
little conceive these the little kind of
balls the different little little blue
balls or black balls indicate you know
nutrient metabolites coming in and how
they basically diffuse in and out so you
have some size constraints as these are
not vascularized new
trade some ways to have to diffuse in
and out this causes you run into some
sort of physical constraints on the
right this shows an image this is taken
of this FG two cells that were formed
deforming these aggregates and what you
can you can see that the zones are
indicated in the arrows the blue this is
basically just a nuclei stain so each of
a little round each of little the blue
spheres is a nuclei four cell and then
in the center you can see the necrotic
core so this was you thanks to assess
the the integrity of cells in the sphere
and so consistent with the cartoon model
we see a bit of this sort of interior
region that is dead or dying at least
under these conditions
okay so so why would we want to form two
men you know hepatis fears or spheroids
these would be taking these would be
serving with primary human and panel
sights the workflow is shown on the
right here so we would actually take a
vial of frozen cells plate them in a
ultra low attachment round bottom a
plate in this case we use our nunc Tara
plate and they form they'll go for
steroids or aggregate and self-assemble
into these four words steroids over five
days or so one of the main reasons why
this is useful with hepatic biology is
that typically human primary hatate
sites that cannot last in it can't be
cultured for for very long in fact five
to six days is very typical after that
they lose activity they leave viability
and contrast the hepatocyte s-- the same
cells when cultured asteroid's can
retain viability and appropriate
activity for weeks and and this is this
is advantageous because
here's a graph showing one of the key
activities but but for hepatic biology
you may have compounds that that are
there in the low turnover conference so
that they take a while to be days on the
order of days to be metabolized and
you'd like to have a culture window in
which you could basically assess the
turnover of all sorts of compounds not
just those that you can measure within
basically a five-day window that one can
do now with it with the primary pliva
toccata side so so again this is one
where you get improved activity so this
is showing if I look at the bottom left
we're looking at a cytochrome p port
p450 the subject that the three a-four
isoform it's activity is greatly
improved in thyroid culture and then
this is maintained even higher than the
monolayer cultures out out to three
weeks similarly we'll look at albumin
production a key marker of the quality
of the cells that paddock cells all much
higher in in the spheroid versus the the
exact same cells cultured and monolayer
and in this case we're looking at this
is again sip three a four levels over
time so yeah so that again this is a
case where we get in culturing the cells
and steroids get a better viability
better longevity and greater sensitivity
to to certain metabolites and pathways
that are really important for poor folks
looking at you know drug safety drug
testing at me talks tech works okay so
that's just a touch on that so I'm going
to give you another example
this is using an IP SC sells for for
investigating molecular aspects of
Parkinson's disease and so just a quick
bit on Parkinson's it's a it's a
degenerative
degenerative disease that that's caused
by the loss of a specific sub population
of neurons that then emanate from the
from the emanate from the substantial
emanate into the substantia [ __ ] and
these cells are there they're a
subpopulation of the dopamine-producing
neurons which the loss of these cells
are really what drives the passive
physiologic types of physiological
conditions of Parkinson's disease which
is form a fairly common and really quite
awful neurodegenerative disease and it's
an area of intense focus
so
one of the ways and this is this is work
that we're this is really I'm laying out
a roadmap of how we're looking at doing
some studies in in 3d and this is a part
leveraging moving from 2d reagents and
culture systems into 3d and seeing how
how can we use that can can we learn new
or interesting things about the disease
and ways to potentially intervene or or
screen candidates or potential therapies
in 3d that we were not able to you know
that would be unique then with the 3d
system and so specifically this is a bit
of an outline of what the workflow looks
like and this is this is actually
something we're working on in-house
right now but but we'd start with in the
case of the IPS see lines we can start
with a wild-type an individual with a
normal healthy individual without
Parkinson's and then individuals or more
specific mutations that are associated
with with Parkinson's disease at the
upper left so we're looking at the LR
rk2 this is a lark to kinase there's a
one familiar new table there's this is
communication associated with the
disease there's another one that
instrument Queen a that's listed below
so so these are just basically a IPS
derived from patients with Parkinson's
disease we can using a kit we developed
a couple of years ago to create these
very specific midbrain floorplate
derived dopamine precursors expand the
progenitors and then put them into this
and to see Roy put them into an extended
3d phase in this case this would be
after they've had been specified to be
neurons or neural precursors and then
what we want to do is look at you know
look across the different patient cohort
and then stress the cells in variety of
ways and then looking at various
endpoints and this is just acting kind
of highlighting both some of the
challenges and opportunities of dealing
with the cells in these types
structures so looking at the bottom left
where we be replating the spheroids and
watching and then assessing how the
neurons grow out of these steroids
across the different patient cohorts we
can look at very specific cell migration
so we can look at over overall neuron
outgrowth we can actually track
migration specifically then we can start
to optically slice into these different
conditions and in different cells then
the other paths for us are the more
destructive or dissociative ones where
we can actually enzymatically digest
liberate the cells from the steroid do
either art so individual RNA sickle cell
RNA seek facts analysis once we've got
these cells individualized and then also
leverage you know rt-pcr and other other
types of we can actually do some system
histology on these too so so this gives
us now kind of a roadmap on how we how
we're thinking about leveraging you know
the ability to put these cells in 2d and
assess features that are related to the
different genetic you know patient
populations with with responses and
looking at these are these th these
tyrosine hydroxylase or dopamine
producing cell types specifically does
something we're very excited about about
doing so if I switch gears a little bit
now moving into the some examples of the
adult tissue derived organoids so this
is circling back a bit so so what do we
so you know what are what what does this
really mean so so it's essentially
harnessing the ability to capture
isolate or a clone only sort of outgrow
resident progenitors so tissue specific
progenitors and you know a number of the
the tissues are shown here
these can also you know so these types
of organized from these tissues from
normal and diseased are cancerous tissue
so again very very powerful tools to
enable the study of developmental
biology to you know to recapitulate
these tissues for four core disease
modeling and and for you know cancer
oncology studies
um you know the app the applications for
the organoids are abroad this shows
again you know many different ways one
could think about using them again I
think I touched a little bit on the
personalized drug development there are
potential you know at least certainly
interest in therapeutic applications of
the organoids although that's a these
the days are still early now but but
certainly a lot of promise there so
going you know going back into people or
or informing about you know informing
clinical informing and guiding clinical
decisions as well as being used
therapeutically the right paths are more
of the sort of in vitro applications of
these so so really quite diverse and and
exciting to see where we're you know the
field is going where it will go the next
slide just highlights to you know real
world examples of the value of fees of
these adult stem cell models in in
therapeutic applications so this is
actually work from our different
investigators in in the Netherlands
one showing basically it's really both
papers are actually really really quite
quite amazing but the the functionality
of the paper on the left here was
essentially using patient-derived
intestinal organs to screen for
basically a practical screen of drugs or
therapeutic agents to treat cystic
fibrosis and in ways that that
essentially the drugs could be that the
therapy could be screened ex vivo to
look for to to better fit in a shinto
vidual patients the genetic background
or susceptibility to respond to the
different compounds so so really pretty
pretty remarkable applications this
and the other on the right is really
looking at kind of a paper demonstrating
the fidelity in which the cancer derives
breast cancer derived to muroids
recapitulate the primary tumors and and
thus become you know interesting and and
and at least somewhat fateful models for
studying oncology there that that is not
it's hard to do and it really can't be
done in standard 2d those really really
need stuff
okay and again I this is a this is just
a figure taken from the CFTR work that
shows one can actually go in and correct
edit meet the CFTR associated mutations
with a CRISPR cast 9 approach then
screen these these edited patient
patient and patient corrected cells in
in the organoid assay and show they show
what sort of repair about the loss of
disease phenotype so sort of a proven
concept for repair okay so lastly the
what I wanted to go over was just a
characterization and analysis of these
complex structures because this is
really not a trivial thing at all
and as I mentioned earlier many there's
a lot of adapting 2d methodology to 3d
biology and it in some cases leaves
please collect quite a bit to be desired
so this is certainly an area where much
work and development is is needed but
you know I think one of the things that
sort of goes without saying is the
quality of your material is critical
your cellular material so in this case
you know if you're starting with IPSC or
pork stem cell direct models you want to
have pluripotent stem cell you want to
have high-quality cultures before you
start these these long long expensive
experiments you want to know that the
material going in is of you know highest
quality and so with with IPS ES you know
we we serve our scientific offers a
variety of tools that helps you assess
the poi potency of your cells or these
are they you know are they pluripotent
and does the line have the ability to
give rise to all all three germ lines so
so key key features of a IPSC cell so we
have our both pleura test and tack man
scorecard to address Corie potency the
ability to give rise to
various germ lines and then the curio
set this is a digital karyotyping tool
and again this is a way to assess a
genomic integrity of yourself
particularly important with IPS see
cells that have a pickup state
genetically unstable
so as I mentioned a couple of times
these are long protocols so the ability
to do in process sampling and QC is
really quite useful here's a couple of
examples that we we commonly employ
depending on the type of cell and the
length of the protocol but visually
monitoring the aggregate formation this
is a relatively simple and
straightforward one we can you know we
do this with with our ethos imaging
system one can continue this using a
variety of methods it's a very good and
relatively simple and low low complexity
way of getting a good sense of
consistency overall you know consistency
between a process if you learn this
reproducibly are the swords growing that
have a similar size and shape are they
you know are they consistent within
within a batch all really really
important features can also pull these
out if it's a longer workflow pull them
out and do a sample differentiation or
look for key marker expression whether
it's by QT CR or other other means to
determine you know are the cells
progressing in a way that you expect
them to
yeah we've also had been looking at
adapting many of our 2d cell health
reagents and other tools to 3d
applications and and we're finding some
translate relatively well others are are
a little bit a little bit more
challenging or require specific workflow
or protocol modifications as a general
rule of thumb the qPCR the approaches
used there translate very well the an
applications with antibodies depend on
many many different things penetration
into a staining an image in these
complex sometimes rather large
structures is there is a real challenge
just being able to do optical slicing in
do either embedding and physical slicing
all depending on the model that you're
doing what you want to look at through
all approaches that you may may want to
employ and really starts to fall into
the space of almost histological
analysis depending on the size of some
of these so so their protocol
optimization for these structures is
really is really quite important I know
for many of our cell health reagents and
other imaging and analysis tools we
Thermo Fisher Scientific are putting out
specific application notes and guidance
on how to handle it and as well as
special specialized reagents to create
more standardized and hopefully
consistent protocols for analysis of
these types of structures
again here's many of the instrument
platforms that we would be doing for for
for imaging a plate reader based
analysis with with some of the cell
health reagents
the thumbs
um
so I'll just leave you with this is a
some images of sorta neural organoids at
these are just about three months old
that we had fixed and done the cryo
embedment slicing and histology
immunochemical standing on so it's a lot
of work to get to this point three
months of culture and a week or so of
handling and staining that you can end
up you know generating is very lovely
very complex structures what you'd what
you'd see in here these are the
formation of these sort of neural
rosette or neural progenitor rains or
rosettes that clearly are visible within
the larger Horn
okay with that I'll just go to a wrap-up
I hope this was interesting and at least
somewhat informative for you you know
what we really wanted to try and achieve
or at least to highlight you know the
differences in the types of 3d
structures that one can form you know
with different types of materials or
different starting points and how they
compare broadly to their 2d brethren
some of the you know sort of a
challenges and and key parts of the
workflow with these and and again you
know what what what we you know what
we're doing now and what we'd like to
see and support in the further
advancement of of these models and in
basic discovery and in clinical with
with with with clinical applications
okay so with that I think I will
I'll wrap and I think I can go to Krissy
I think we might have a few a few
questions we can we can thank you yes
David
yes thank you David for that informative
presentation we do have questions that
have come in and if you'd like to ask
David a question please click on the ask
a question box located at the far left
of your screen and we'll answer as many
questions that we have time for okay
let's get started
David our first question how do I tell
if 3d is right for my project it seems
like a lot of work compared to
traditional monolayer culture
yeah that that that's a good question
and I I don't think there's a there's
not a simple unfortunately I don't think
that there's not a simple answer I think
from from my perspective it's really it
depends on you know what what you're
doing what what what what types of
questions that you're trying to ask
I mean maybe an example I'll give you a
specific example of this might help I
think that for example if you are
studying someone who is you know
studying complex but let's say a complex
complex neurological disease like
schizophrenia for example or or
Alzheimer's where there they're
different it's not a single mutation
it's not a single cell type that's it's
a variety of cells it's a network
disruption and communication and
interactions between multiple cell types
that can be very very difficult to
recapitulate in 2d you know either
creating all these different cell types
individually and mixing them together or
another approach is to take this you
know form these cortical or these these
organoids that will be the process of
sort of undergoing development in in
this sort of 3d structure will naturally
form or can be coaxed to form many many
of these different cell types in an
architecture that at least somewhat
resembles the sort of in vitro in vivo
situations so so you can if you're
studying something that's complex this
is a very nice way to model something
that's complex and and but but that
comes at a cost from you know kind of
time and throughput so I think it's
really you know what you're studying and
does do the types of models are they
really going to add value
you know relative to to 2d so that's
that's not a very clear answer but
that's but that that would be my my two
cents
thanks David our next question what do
you see are the major hurdles in
establishing and routinely using 3d
culture
yeah that's a good question too I think
to me that's a little bit more
straightforward
the the again it depends a little bit on
the model that we're talking about but
generally it's consistency some models
are more consistent than others though
but so consistency scale up scale and
and I guess you know scales in the eye
of the beholder so to speak but if you
want to get a sort of large scale you
know farm a level screening on these you
you build those are still real
challenges time some of the workflows
take it again this can vary depending on
the model so some of the models
particularly the IPSC derived you know
organoid models can take months to form
well and so boy that's that's a while
and then then the assays again we
touched on this a little bit in the
slide that the the breadth of the assays
can be limiting for for some of the 3d
structures so it's so advancement in in
imaging and other types of analysis
tools that are more compatible for 3d
this is still a challenge
you
okay our next question why are most of
the adult organoids derived from
epithelial tissues
yeah that that I think basically some my
sense on this is that they are
the epithelial so these epithelial
tissues in general are undergo constant
renewal that's the sort of you know how
they sort of how they're they're built
so they have a relatively robust
population of you know stem cells or
progenitor 's that give rise to it you
know that are just that are there for
the normal health and a sort of
maintenance of the tissue so and I think
they're just and there's some
commonality between epithelial cells
from different tissues so I think that
they the approaches that work for one
epithelial cell type can broadly be
applied not even though there's there's
certainly some some improvement required
there are some tweaking required but can
be applied to other other epithelial
cell types other tissue types are a
little bit either they don't naturally
regenerate as much as the epithelial
cells so I think I think the resident
stem cell or progenitor population is
lower or we're just not as good at
finding them and pulling them out of the
tissue so I think again expect to see
more improvements as we understand more
about these other non epithelial
progenitors but I think that's that's
you know sort of my my sense of things
at least
thank you David now we have time for
just one more question but I want to
remind our audience that any question we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on demand period
will be addressed by david via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration our final question
for today let's let's go with this one
it's Thermo Fisher Scientific developing
new reagents designed to improve 3d
workflows
yeah that's a question I really like
absolutely I mean I think we're trying
to do you know we're we at Surma Fisher
Scientific are really tool providers and
we love to you know support you know the
research you know researchers in you
know a wider array of endeavors and and
we've been following you know kind of
the evolution horse this evolution but
but you know as a 3d as the sort of the
latest and very exciting way for 3d
biology with with much interest and so I
think our approach has been kind of
multi fold what one is you know where
you know what's easy what can we adapt
what what do we have now that can be
readily adapted to either use for
culture you know for a creation of these
models or the analysis of them so it's
so kind of our first and we look at and
see what people are doing what's the
field doing and it's it's for the most
part taking reagents and models that
were designed for 2d for the most part
and then applying them in 3d so so the
first part is you know can we not
repurpose that provide better guidance
on current tools the second part you
know our second sort of piece of that is
yeah we've been looking actively looking
really even across the company at the
development or bringing in and
developing new types of tools that are
really specific for for 3d applications
whether they're improved ways to fix and
visualize these complicated structures
you know applications on our confocal
high-content imaging system or other you
know other other other technical
platforms that we have which are which
are quite diverse you know applying them
in 3d and then even maybe a little
closer home to home for me and my team
is looking at you know looking at
developing culture reagents specifically
for 3d applications so instead of
for example just buying you know taking
a bottle of DM f12 and using it in a 3d
application what if we built the media
that you know the reagents specifically
for 3d applications and would they work
better and I think these are the basis
the type of stuff we're looking at right
now also too to see how could can we
make some you know a range of
improvements there so yeah so kind of
sorry bit of a rambling answer very
interesting space for us we're actively
looking to again provide better tools
and reagents for the cleanup for the
research community I guess I'll leave it
at that
thank you David and thanks for
clarifying these basic questions and
enabling us to get started using repeat
cultural systems now have any final
comments for our audience
Oh final comments um you know I would
just personally I find you know this is
it's a very very exciting time in
biology right now we you know we in our
sort of post genomic era the ability to
engineer and edit and now be able to
create these very complicated structures
recapitulate them in vitro it's really
remarkable so I would you know the there
is an awful lot of need for creative
solutions and thoughtful approaches to
using his model so I just say you know
there's a there's pursuit it's an
exciting time there's a huge need and I
think it's really just your your
imaginations limit here so I didn't you
know okay sure it just helped it to do
well and yeah so that's my sort of
philosophical ending to the webinar
thanks David
and and you do help make this even more
exciting we appreciate your time and
your efforts in your research we also
want to take lab roots and our sponsor
Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
now before we go I want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions again if we
didn't answer your question or if you
would like to submit questions during
the on-demand period David will be
responding via email to the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through August of 2019 lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's ready for a replay we encourage you
to share that email with your colleagues
so they who may have missed today's live
event you will now be redirected to the
second part of our series getting
started in 3d thanks for joining us
goodbye